the day is 26 february 2022
the world is hit with breaking news that
russian state tv channels have been
hacked by anonymous a hacktivist
collective and movement who have made a
name taking part in multiple cyber wars
in the past decade
this was in response to the russian
aggression on ukrainian territory in the
hopes of annexation
anonymous hacked the russian state tv
networks to combat propaganda in russia
and highlight the damage to life meted
out by the kremlin in ukraine they also
hacked 120 000 russian troops personal
information and the russian central bank
stealing 35 000 files
this served as a clear indicator of how
cyber war can change the momentum in
battle something which people had never
seen so closely
so what is cyber war
a digital assault or series of strikes
or hacks against a country is sometimes
referred to as a cyber war it has the
ability to cause havoc on government and
civilian infrastructure as well as
disrupt essential systems causing state
harm and even death
in this day and age the internet plays a
bigger role than just watching videos
and learning content
it's where you have your personal data
and carry financial transactions so
rather than resorting to physical
violence cyber wars become the new means
to cause havoc considering the
vulnerability of the data passing
through the internet
in most circumstances cyber warfare
involves a nation-state attacking
another
in certain cases the assaults are
carried out by terrorist organizations
or non-state actors pursuing a hostile
nation's aim in june 2021 chinese
hackers targeted organizations like
verizon to secure remote access to their
networks stuxnet was a computer worm
designed to attack iran's nuclear
facilities but evolved and expanded to
many other industrial and energy
producing sites in 2010
since the definition of cyber war is so
vague applying rules and sanctions based
on digital assault is even tougher
making the field of cyber warfare a
lawless land not bound by any rules or
policies
there are multiple ways in which these
attacks can be carried out a major
category of cyber attack is espionage
espionage entails monitoring other
countries to steal critical secrets
this might include compromising
vulnerable computer systems with botnets
or spear phishing attempts before
extracting sensitive data in cyber
warfare
the next weapon in cyber war is sabotage
government agencies must identify
sensitive data and its dangers if it is
exploited
insider threats such as disgruntled or
irresponsible personnel or government
staff with ties to the attacking country
can be used by hostile countries or
terrorists to steal or destroy
information
by overwhelming a website with bogus
requests and forcing it to handle them
denial of service attacks prohibit real
users from accessing it
attacking parties may use this form of
assault to disrupt key operations and
systems and prevent citizens military
and security officials and research
organizations from accessing sensitive
websites
but what benefits does cyberwar offer in
contrast to traditional physical warfare
the most important advantage is the
ability to conduct attacks from anywhere
global without having to travel
thousands of miles
as long as the attacker and target are
connected to the internet organizing and
launching cyber wars is relatively less
tedious than physical warfare
people living in or battling for a
country are subjected to propaganda
attacks in an attempt to manipulate
their emotions and thoughts
digital infrastructure is highly crucial
in today's modern world
starting from communication channels to
secure storage servers crippling a
country's footprint and control on the
internet is very damaging
but what are some of the ways we as
citizens protect ourselves in the case
of a cyber war in the unfortunate event
that your country is involved in warfare
be sure to fact check every piece of
information and follow only trusted
sources in that frame of time
even conversations online should be
limited to a need to know basis
considering propaganda campaigns have
the power to influence the tide of war
drastically
it is highly crucial to follow basic
security guidelines to secure our
devices like regularly updating our
operating systems occasionally running
full system antivirus scans etc
if your country or organization is being
attacked having devices segregated in a
network goes a long way in bolstering
security
try to avoid sharing a lot of personal
data online
in this era of instagram and facebook
divulging private information can be
detrimental to keeping a secure firewall
for your data
the more information an attacker has
access to the higher his chances of
being able to devise a plan to
infiltrate defenses
so here is a question for you
which of the following is the wrong step
to take as a citizen in the event of a
cyber war
one verifying the source of information
first
two
finding secure channels of communication
three
share your whereabouts on social media
to update families and friends four
minimize communication with
non-essential personnel think about it
and leave your answers in the comments
section and we will provide the answer
next week give the correct answer along
with your reasoning and stand a chance
to win an amazon voucher
we hope you enjoyed this video if you
did a thumbs up would be really
appreciated here's your reminder to
subscribe to our channel and click on
the bell icon for more on the latest
technologies and trends thank you for
watching and stay tuned for more from
simplylearn
[Music]
you